quand même quand même roger dumas michel
bouquet vous avez fortement déconseillé
de ne pas vous dit ce père salah et et
vous faites vous écrivait des chansons
et pas qu'un peu
alors pas seulement avec les plus mais
vous en avez écrit et pas qu'un peu
jamais écrit cette s'arrange quoi avec
mon ami jacques d'amours notamment nous
avions écrit la ruine et casino de paris
quand zizi jeanmaire et relance y
compris de casio j'avais écrit tout
autre la revue on a écrit évidemment
capitaine flam on a grondé charton tout
le monde absolument tout le monde yves
montand que monde donc je me suis
beaucoup amusé à écrire des choses et
puis un jour j'avais tourné un film en
espagne et à côté de moi dans l'avion il
y avait michel bouquet qui me dit vous
écrivez toujours des chansons mais oui
vous avez tort
un acteur comme bout de ce 10 personnes
l'autre et toute la vie bang n'est pas
ce que j'écrivais des chansons disons
que vous pouvez faire qu'une seule chose
à la fois et bien maintenant j'ai
compris que pendant qu'on joue une pièce
on peut pas être avant la journée
voilà ça j'aurais compris parce que j'ai
lu les livres de michel j'essaie
d'appliquer un jour il m'a dit roger tu
es dans l' orchestre il faut sortir de
la requête mais pour devenir premier
violon après tu essaieras de devenir
soliste et après tu vivre avec c'est
laurence même si tu ne l'atteint pas
c'est à dire que même à n'importe quel
âge faut essayer de progresser tous
appliquent ça et je suis en termine avec
la chanson vous connaissez tous ceux
comment s'appelle le lapin savez de
créer ce matin de lapins de simples
chantal goya
a tué un chasseur
c'est sale
ce matin
ghsr
parce que dans charlie hebdo il y avait
la rubrique de paul ya chaque fois qu'un
chanteur quand tu as d'hôtels b b lé
petit la place autour de la gueule trop
fait tomber en live à 15 voilà une
personne n'échappe à personne absolument
personne n'y échappe les dames et
messieurs roger dumas qui a écrit cette
chanson